foreign
[Music]
attempting to understand biophysical
function of crispr cas9 through
computational methods um so I will give
you an overview of the background and
significance of this system and then I
will report about the biophysics and the
biochemistry of General editing and how
we attempted to understand it through
computational methods and finally there
will be a chapter on the specificity of
genome editing I think that I don't have
to introduce the importance of this
system to this community as you know
this system triggered a revolutionary
faith in biology with applications in
many fields what we are interested in is
in understanding how it works and how we
can improve it this system comes from a
bacterial immune response again against
invading data virus which triggers
the action of this protein cas9 that
binds RNA and uses its sequence
information to Target the DNA and
perform double stranded DNA cleavages as
we like to say this system works a
little bit like an ideal silk artist
where there is a protein that in this
case is the artist that first binds to
RNA changes conformation to grab DNA and
match it so there are several
conformational changes allostatic and of
Target effects that involve the
biophysics of this system and we are
interested in understanding how these
phenomena happen
through
molecular simulations
let's focus on the biophysics of
genomialism how does it bind nucleic
acids
so as you can imagine these
conformational changes that we are
investigating are very large
conformational changes of this protein
so these are conformational changes that
require long-time scale Dynamics
millisecond time scale micro two
millisecond time scales and the
confidence of our biomolecular
simulations I would say is in this range
so what we want to do is to get out of
our comfort zone to push the frontiers
of our methods and reach a scales that
were not reached before
to do so we use a quantum mechanical
methods the classical force field and of
course cryo-em processing methods and
the first question we have been
attempting to answer is the mechanism of
RNA binding so this was our first
um our first my first paper in which we
in which I investigated how the protein
changes conformation to bind RNA and as
you can see our simulations could
retrace the conformational change the
very large conformational changes of
this recognition lobe and how it changes
with respect to the other domain to this
Arginine Rich Helix to grab RNA and
reconciling what was observed through
the first
cryo structures obtained through
negative stamina
then we moved to the understanding of
the conformational Dynamics of the
catalytic H domain so this domain uh the
Dynamics of this domain is important to
regulate the function of cas9 Since By
docking at the cleavage side it performs
cleavage but it was also shown that
dynamics of H and H governs the entire
function of cas9 so what we have been
doing is to map the conformational
Dynamics of H and H from the inactive to
active state by running accelerated
molecular Dynamic simulations when we
started these simulations the active
structure was not present in the
literature
and we actually found that by running
extensive molecular simulations the H
and H domain would Dock at the cleavage
site dynamically in the microsecond time
scale so this observation was then
supported with score operated later a
couple of years later by two structures
appearing in in the literature to cry
OEM structures capturing the active
state of hna hmm and we found that there
was a predicted error between the
cryo-year map and the atomic structure
that we predicted which was very low
which was a actually a very good
achievement for molecular Dynamic
simulations I think so based on this
knowledge of the H and H Dynamics we
decided to investigate how the hnh
Dynamics controls the allosteric
function of cas9 so two seminal papers
appeared in the literature before us to
papers
using molecular biology in these papers
it was shown that the hnh conformational
change governs the activation of cas9
activating the catalytic function of the
second catalytic domain which is rabsi
and this activation would be activated
by The Binding of a recognition region
at a distal sides posing the basics for
an allosteric control which at that time
was unknown so to decide to investigate
this allosteric control we are Nest
Network models derived from graph theory
in particular with these models we treat
every residue of the protein and of the
nucleic acids as a node and we calculate
how these nodes correlate dynamically
with each other and what are the
preferred Pathways between one node and
the other what are the pathways between
for example one side that could be the H
and H side and the rough Seaside what
are the shortest pathways shortest
dynamical pathway that maximize the
correlation between one side and the
other so these are the same models that
are used in Facebook and Twitter where
every friend is a node connected by
edges and of course also as as they do
in social media they can identify a
friends that that are the Keynotes of
the network that are connected by more
edges and these are the friends where
the information transfer passes much
faster you don't want to tell them your
secrets but this is basically the same
concept so we can identify Keynotes and
key residues of the system
the entire conformational dynamics of
the protein so we applied these methods
and we identified what we believed to be
the pathway for the information transfer
between the recognition region so where
the DNA binds to the nuclear the domains
and what we could observe is that the
pathwayne obtained with molecular
simulations was overlapping with
residues that were shown by NMR by our
collaborator George Elizabeth Brown
University
um residues that are were shown to be
slow through cpmg relaxation dispersion
which was an indication that this could
have been the route for the information
transfer connecting the site of DNA
binding to the site of DNA cleavage
so with rbsi the two once we identified
this pathway that you see here depicted
in pink from the recognition to the
nucleus robe we decided to investigate
what is the effect of point mutations in
h that have been shown to improve the
specificity of cas9 against against of
Target effects are these mutations
improving the specificity because they
exert some effect on the allostatic
pathway on the signal transmission
so we use the graph Theory also in this
case and we built circular networks of
communication gain and loss within H so
with these models we could describe H as
a set of communities of synchronize the
Dynamics
um here the a communities are the
allostatic communities holding the
majority of those low residues
identified with NMR the transferred
information from one side to the other
the other communities were not
allosteric so with the circular networks
of a loss of communication gain and loss
we could identify if the communication
between allostatic communities gets
broken in the presence of the mutation
which is what actually occurs with an
announced effect
in one of the three mutations with
respect to the other which is this k855a
which was actually in qualitative
agreement with what the
experimental paper reported the
experimental paper report is that
increased specificity of k855a was
higher in the presence of a single point
mutation with respect to the others so
this could already tell us that there is
some relation between the way how this
mutation interrupts the allosteric
transmission with respect to the
function to the activity so of course
this was computed and we wondered how
this would have been a real right so
this is all what we wonder and we
decided to compare with
um NMR NMR data with the experimental
Dynamic exchange so here you can see the
H and H communities which come from the
computations that show synchronized
Dynamics and in Gray you can we quantify
that the information transfer observed
through NMR which is the experimental
Dynamic exchange and you can see that
the three mutation reduce the dynamic
Exchange
in in between between the allostatic
communities which was a was supportive
of what we observed the computationally
suggested that this announce that
specificity mutations uh per tour but
they are lost there is mean H and H and
in turn because of this reason could
impact the specificity of course this is
now an hypothesis that we are
investigating in several other system
and has opened an entire field of
studies um
okay what about the biophys the
biochemistry of genome editing so cas9
Cliffs DNA the two strands of DNA
through true catalytic domains H and
rubsin also in this case we wondered how
is this happening how does cas9 clear
DNA and to understand these uh
um this mechanism we use the quantum
mechanical simulations where the
particular mixed methods where the core
of the system is treated at a quantum
mechanical level and the rest of the
system is treated at the classical level
these are um these are the method that
we use is based on molecular Dynamics
and is actually extremely expensive and
quite complicated it takes for this
simulation takes uh takes takes a lot of
time to run these simulations and and
these are quite expensive
um but it's actually very powerful it is
very powerful because as you can see
here in the case of wrap C we can follow
dynamically analysis from the reactants
to the products so what we observed in
our simulations is that an Arginine
residue that in the crystal structures
was found to be in a different position
was always pointing toward the Chisel
phosphate suggesting a stabilizing role
we also computed the chemical mechanism
revealing an associative mechanism that
was then also was in agreement with
previous
kinetic experiments and was also in
agreement with DNA cleavage experiments
performed by Janice Chen at UC Berkeley
but what is most interesting is that
when we started this project the
structure of the active site was not
available so magnesium were not
introduced in the crystalline cryium
structures who which were available
before
and these are Arginine was actually in a
totally different position the new
structure that appeared very recently
shows that the
active site that we predicted is
actually very accurate
we then moved to the understanding of
the H H catalysis in this case two
catalytic sites were proposed one side
we called it pseudo active and this
definition was given a posteriorly so
this definition was given a posterior
because structures that were obtained uh
in the absence of magnesium or by using
experimental conditions that not
completely
resembles the
um the real the real the real case
scenario suggested this active side in
which this residue would Point toward
magnesium but new Crystal structures and
cryoem structures proposed a different
active site an active site in which
this asparaging would substitute
um the uh the aspartate so to understand
which of these two structure is
catalytic and how the catalysis occurs
we used a variety of computational
methods first of all we performed the
free energy simulations to characterize
the conformational change between the
pseudoactive and active structure in the
presence and absence of magnesium and we
found that with magnesium the active
structure was preferred suggesting that
previous structures supported these
pseudo conformation because of the
absence of the catalytic ion and
suggesting that the catalytic ion also
hold a structural effect then we moved
to the understanding of the chemistry
and in this case we combined NMR
experiments by George Lee with our
prediction of PKA which was rigorously
done through explicit solvent constant
pH and replica exchange and you as you
can see the agreement in the case of the
active confirmation was actually very
was actually excellent suggesting that
the active conformation would be the
catalytic one we then moved to the
characterization of the catalysis
through quantum mechanical simulations
and in this case we used a method called
metadynamics that enabled us to move
from the reactants to the product
showing that this is a histidine
activated mechanism is an associative
mechanism and we also observed something
very interesting where this lies in
engages in the protonation of the living
group so the way how we can look at this
mechanism better is through a movie you
can see in the movie that the system is
actually very large these are more than
400 000 atoms
is actually the biggest system ever
studied with qmm simulations here now we
zoom into the active site and then the
catalysis starts as I said this is fully
done at a dynamical level so we can see
how the system evolves from the
reactants where we are now to the
transition state when we partially break
and partially form a bonds to the
products up to the final observation of
this lysine protonating through a proton
shuttle through a water the O3 Prime so
this was
an observation that required careful
examination and experimental validation
which at the end supported this
mechanism because by substituting these
lies in the catalysis actually does not
occur
finally I would like to spend some words
on the mechanism of Target effects so of
Target effects are the unselected
cleavage of DNA strands that do not
match the RNA guide bearing base pair
mismatches so this work was initially
inspired by single molecule experiment
by Chen and dagdas in this a single
molecule experiment here
schematically depicted here you can see
that in the presence of four base pair
mismatches at the end of the hybrid H
and H can assume an inactive
conformation unable to cleave the DNA
but in the presence of three to one
mismatches H and H progressively assumes
an active conformation similar to what
is observed in the On Target system and
is able to cleave the DNA so your target
of course and we wondered why this
experimental observation we wonder what
is the molecular mechanical is not the
basis of this observation so we did
announce it we used enhanced molecular
Dynamic simulations of the system in the
presence of mismatches and we observe
that in the presence of four mismatches
there is an extended opening of the
hybrid which results in locking the
catalytic H H domain strong binding of
the catalytic hcnh domain Indina in
locking it into the inactive
conformation
which could explain the reason why it
does not activate or is unlikely to
activate in the presence of mismatch in
all four base permissions
so these results were very recently
confirmed by Crystal structures obtained
by Martin ginac
who has shown that before base and
mismatches at the end of the hybrid lead
to this opening of the hybrid observed
previously in our simulation So based on
this success so we decided to partner
with
um with Martin to
investigate what would happen if the
mismatches would be located along the
hybrid so first of all we have tested we
tested our method at positions where the
crystal structures were available
for example you can see in this case and
in this case we can find a confirmation
of the adenine adenine mismatch that is
similar to what Martin observed but for
the other positions where Crystal
structures were for which Crystal
structures were not present we used
enhanced molecular stimulations to
predict the conformations of mismatches
and this is a movie of the of Target
interactions underlying
um The Binding of mismatched sequences
at the level of
um H you can see the Locking of H and H
in the presence of four base pair
mismatches and finally I would like to
thank all of you for your attention of
course I would like to thank my grouper
who has been instrumental in pursuing
this research in particular our graduate
students
Shaha then the postdoc Pablo Arantes
Lucas
who did all the app initial molecular
Dynamic simulations and of course all
the others the funding agencies the our
collaborators and all of you for your
attention
so I was wondering Ken Johnson's model
for the catalytic turnover of crispr
cast 9 shows a single turnover model
that's your mechanistic simulations shed
some light on that
so my um from the the work of Ken
Johnson which is actually this one right
so this is the work of Ken Johnson
so Ken Johnson reported the Decay cat of
uh of the catalysis and in terms of
k-cat we agree for both active sites
both hnh and rap C what is interesting
is that DK cat in this case was measured
um was measured after The Binding of the
nucleic acids so too is a is a measure
that basically is directly referred to
the step of cleavage which was great
because we could fairly compare it with
our simulations accordingly of course to
the assumptions that are present in
transition state Theory regarding your
questions of the single turnover
multiple turnover our simulations looked
at the step of of cleavage right so we
did not simulate what would happen after
the cleavage which is something actually
we could do but I don't expect the
system to give rise to um uh to very
large conformational changes to enable a
new cleavage if this can answer your
question
so maybe there is a point I I could make
to this audience that actually this is
an experimental audience and I think
it's very interesting uh this point I
think that we are assisting at some
Breakthrough by by single molecule
experiments and it's actually very
exciting to see that with single
molecule experiment you can measure the
Tau cleavage which is the time required
for actually the cleavage so with single
molecule experiments you can measure the
time required for the conformational
change then you can measure the time
required for the cleavage so I think
that this can be
parameters that can be used in the
future to compare with our
um with our data so this could be more
accurate parameters to compare with the
with our data I think
many many assumptions with this with
this comparison this is important to
mention
okay thank you Julia